وقال الكريم لن ان الرئيس الروسي فلاديمير
بوتين دعا المستشار الالماني او لاف شونس
الى اعاده النظر في موقف المانيا ايذاء
الوضع في اوكرانيا وفي اتصال هاتفي بينهما
لفت بوتن انتباه شولتس الى النهج المدمر
للغرب الذي يمد كيف بالاسلحه ويدرب
العسكريين وفقا تعبير الكرملين كما اكد
بوتين لشولس ان القوات الروسيه امتنعت
لفتره طويله عن توجيه ضربات على اوكرانيا
وان الاجراءات الحاليه هي اجراءات قصريه
ووفقه الكريم للفقد اكد بوتين على ضروره
اجراء تحقيق شفاف في حادثه خط انابيب
نورسين بمشاركه روسيا في المقابل قال
متحدث باسم الحكومه الالمانيه
زاد في الاتصال مع بوتن القذف الروسي
للمنشات المدنيه الاخرانيه ووفقا المتحدث
الالماني فقد حدث شغل قتل على حل النزاع
مع اوكرانيا بالدبلوماسيه وسحب الق من
اوكرانيا
معنا من واشنطن مراسل الجزيره ناصر
الحسيني ومن موسكو مدير مكتب الجزيره زور
شوج لعلي ابدى معك زاور من الاذى الاتصال
بين الرئيس الروسي والالماني وهذا الاعلان
عن فشل موغوصف
بتفاوض او بين الولايات المتحده الامريكيه
ومع نيته وكذلك منظمه التعاون الاوروبيه
ماذا عن هذه المواقف
الاتصال
همم الكلام نايم في همم
تفاصيل هذا الاتصال قال ركز على مساله
اساسيه هي ضربه البنيه التحتيه لاطاقه في
اوكرانيا بان هذا الاجراء كان قصريا كان
اضطراريا بعد ان امتنعت لفتره طويله
القوات الروسيه من استهداف هذه المشاهدات
وجاء بعد ان بدات اوكرانيا باستهداف
المشاهدات الحيويه في اشاره مباشره الى
استهداف جسر القرب همم كما نعلم الذي ادى
الى الحق ضرر كبير في هذه المنشاه الحيويه
بالنسبه لروسيا ولكن فيما يتعلق همم فشل
المفاوضات المتحدث باسم كريم لان كان يقصد
بدرجه الاولى عبد القادر تلك المفاوضات
التي بدات قبل الحرب في اوكرانيا في نهايه
العمل وبدايه العامه الحالي عندما تقدمت
روسيا بحزمه من المبادرات التي اصبحت تعرف
بمقتراحات الضمانات الامنيه قدمتها
وتفاوضت عليها مع حل شمال الاطلسي مع
انظمه الامر والتعاون في اوروبا ومع
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه بشكل منفصل كل
هذه المقترحات الروسيه همم لم تلقى اي
موافقه واي تايد واي رغبه لدى تلك الاطراف
على الاقل هكذا ما تراه موسكو لبحثها او
الموافقه عليها مما دفع موسكو الان اا بعد
ذلك الى الدخول في العمليه العسكريه في
اوكرانيا ما تشتريته همم الدول الغربيه
الولايات المتحده المانيا بانهاء الحرب
وسحب القوات الروسيه هو شرط مستحيل
بالنسبه لروسيا هذا ما اعلنه همم اكثر من
همم مصدر في سرعه في مراكز صنع القرار
وخاصه في الكريملين وبالتالي يبدو ان
الامور تسير في اطار حلقه
مفرغه الروس يريدون ان يحقق اهدافها من
كان عبر العمليه العسكريه المستمره
المتواصله او عبر التفاوض الذي لا تدعو
اليه روسيا روسيا مستعده حسب ان تستمع الى
اي مقترحات في مسائل التفاوض بناجح السلمي
ولكن ترى ان الدول الغربيه
لاوكرانيا عسكريا لا تسعى فعليا همم لدفع
تسويه سياسيه وانما بتوتر وتازين هذا صراع
المستمر واستمراريه